so did you guys do like a family thing
this year for Halloween my kids are too
independent
I don't accept that
sorry
I don't accept that I sat my kids down
like a year or two ago and I said listen
to me
it's very important that we have a
themed Halloween a family costume it's
important to me like I basically said
I'm trying to be vulnerable here it's
very important to Mommy I want to feel
included yeah part of it I don't want to
feel scattered I want to feel like a
team so I'll do you can do whatever you
want for school but at home would you
consider being selfless and doing this
because it's so important to Mommy
I mean I know I wasn't trying to shame I
was trying to be vulnerable and say you
have things that are super important to
you yeah
so we did the Sanderson sisters I love
it it was great
I love it and Dax doesn't love dressing
up he didn't take as kindly to that
conversation but he did not mind wearing
a full black spandex suit and he does a
hay ride every year for all of our
neighbors and he reminds me of my
childhood that's all we did yeah get in
the truck like put the hay in the back
of the truck and he had the trailer yeah
yeah it's pretty fun that's so cool I
love that you don't see stuff like that
here in La I've never heard of that well
you do on hillbilly Lane
I like hillbilly Lane that's my people
um so do your girls do they share their
candy because my kids also sometimes
they share because they want what the
other one has they'll do trades yes but
usually it's like a big hands-off
situation I mean like trying to install
the like if you fill up this Ziploc
um of full of candy bars maybe we'll get
a toy instead just to limit the sugar
but it just never works so I'm just like
listen get sick if you're gonna get sick
yeah that's on you yeah not me and
sometimes that's helpful because then
they learn because my daughter used to
do ice cream and I go girl you can't
have I I don't think you're hearing me
you're lactose intolerant and like she's
not she's not hearing me and I'm like
both of your parents are so like this is
not a good end game and finally I had to
like let her figure that out and she
will limit herself a bit now I think
letting them figure it out is the that's
at least the route that I take because
then you make it a red button and you
don't allow it then they just want to
push back and I'm like okay eat the
amount of candy you want and see how you
feel yeah and listen I'm always like
check in with your body check in with it
that's what I yell from the other room
how are we checking in with our bodies
they hate me
I love so annoying to be the greatest
show to watch
[Music]
[Applause]